اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
شابين برصاص قوه الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها
لمدينه نابلس على الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
قوته نفذت عمليه امنيه في نابلس لاعتقال
مطلوبين على صله بهجوم حوار الذي وقع قبل
اسبوع وادى لاصابه ثلاثه جنود من جنود
الاحتلال وقال شهود الاعيان ان قوه
اسرائيليه محتله اقتحمت صباح اليوم حي
المخفيه بمدينه نابلس فاندلعت اشتباكات
مسلحه
ومواجهات مع الشبان الفلسطينيين استخدم
فيها جيشه الاحتلال الرصاصه الحيه
والمطاطي والقنابل الغازيه وقد وثق مقطع
فيديو لحظه استهدافي قناصه الاحتلال للشاب
محمد الحلاق بينما كان يشتبك مع قوات
الاحتلال عقب اقتحامها المدينه
وفي بيان لها قالت مجموعه عرين الاسود في
نابلس النقاتليها تصدقوا لقوات الاحتلال
واشتبكوا معها خلال اقتحامها مدينه نابلس
صباح اليوم واكدت مجموعه عرين الاسود انا
مقاتلها قوه الاحتلال بوابل من الرصاص
واللعبوه محليه الصنع